[Música]
cuando yo estudié e ingresé a estudiar
derecho pensé que iba a trabajar con la
justicia y voy a trabajar con la
justicia voy a hacer justicia en mi vida
la verdad es que con los años me fui
dando cuenta que en realidad nosotros
los abogados trabajamos con las palabras
trabajamos con las palabras las frases
los acuerdos sociales los consensos
sociales
y por tanto les voy a hablar de las
palabras les voy a hablar de las
palabras del lenguaje con el tiempo fui
trabajando además en una casualidad era
chica y flaca no como ahora y cabían las
alcantarillas por tanto empecé a cablear
las redes de la escuela cable las redes
de redes y por tanto hoy en día hago
clases en ingenierías y en derecho en
ingeniería un par de veces me han pedido
el certificado de abogado porque no
creen que pueda ser el abogado y luego
de eso con la vida también empecé a
trabajar en medicina con los médicos
entonces hago ahora clases en medicina
en ingeniería en derecho entonces tengo
una ensalada asociadas palabras que son
las que quiero transmitirles la verdad
es que el bullying es un nombre
artístico para una situación que hemos
vivido todos nosotros toda nuestra vida
tenemos noción de eso y recuerdos de
esos cierto de hecho si ustedes empiezan
a pensar en su infancia reciente o más
lejana van a acordarse muchas
situaciones que fueron objeto de
maltrato la verdad es que somos una
sociedad maltratadora y el que tiene
poder maltrata al que percibe más débil
y el débil a su vez también siente la
angustia del maltrato y se genera ahí
una especie de círculo vicioso en donde
el que maltrata me potenciado su poder
frente a la angustia del maltratado y va
surgiendo esto no yo fue objeto de
maltrato es verdad pero después te das
cuenta que en realidad es nuevamente lo
que hemos hecho es trabajar con las
palabras palabras que quieren palabras
que duelen
y las palabras son ambiguas de hecho si
yo pienso en una granada piensen en una
granada
una granada
para mí una granada es un fruto
delicioso que estaba en el patio de mi
casa que se abría y que estaba llena de
benito pero si yo viva en una situación
de guerra en un país que está en guerra
y en conmoción cuando digo me cayó una
granada no pienso que me cayó un fruto
delicioso sino que cayó algo que nos
mató a todos ya entonces cuando tú
tienes las palabras y tienes al otro
enfrente empiezas a generar de alguna
manera un círculo virtuoso entre tu
palabra y la reacción del otro
esa es la comunicación que nosotros
conocimos hoy día los niños se comunican
de otra manera los niños se comunican a
través del teléfono el mismo teléfono
que nosotros les pasamos cuando éramos
eran pequeños y estábamos en el
restaurant y nosotros queríamos esperar
la comida tranquilo y que ellos nos lo
dieran le pasamos el teléfono porque se
entretuvieran por miembros y el mismo
teléfono que tienen en sus piezas en su
velador y que de alguna manera los
invaden toda su vida cuál es la
diferencia entonces yo nací en 1968 en
ese tiempo el mundo también quería
cambiar también habían movimientos
sociales sin embargo en esa época la
gente se coordinaba de otra manera para
ir a manifestarse y se comunicaba
también de otra manera no recuerda
incluso más atrás se dice que cuando fue
la primera guerra mundial el la guerra
había terminado los comunas los monarcas
y los jerarcas se habían puesto de
acuerdo y tres meses después en los
campos de batalla la gente se seguía
matando
porque no había un flujo de comunicación
que les permitiera comunicarse en tiempo
real
no quiero decir por tanto que la
tecnología y la comunicación sean mala
porque si hubiéramos tenido whatsapp en
esa época habría bastado mandarle un
whatsapp nos pusimos de acuerdo no se
sigan matando y no se habrían evitado a
estas vidas ser tontos en la tecnología
no es ni buena ni mala
el tema en el fondo es que de alguna
manera cuando nosotros éramos niños
estábamos en el colegio y el maltrato si
se circunscribía a un espacio el colegio
a unas horas las horas de clase cierto y
de alguna manera tú volvías a tu casa tu
zona de confort hoy en día el maltrato
éste es persistente se mantiene en el
tiempo te llega un mensaje de odio o de
mala onda a las 12 de la noche a la una
de la mañana a las dos de la mañana a
las tres de la mañana y de acoso
de distinta naturaleza entonces la
verdad es que no tiene reposo el
maltrato de díaz cuando hablamos de
bullying hablamos en el definitiva en
situaciones de acoso y maltrato
persistentes en el tiempo reiterativas y
con un alto impacto en el sentido de que
el bullying no no solamente te afecta en
tu casa sino que puede estar tu imagen
colgada en internet y re identificarse
progresivamente durante mucho tiempo y
generar por tanto una estigmatización de
la persona que está puesta en el ojo del
huracán durante mucho tiempo sin embargo
nosotros como padres no nos damos cuenta
que nosotros mismos somos en parte los
causantes de esta situación porque
subimos fotos humillantes de nuestros
hijos a las redes
subimos diálogos que ellos tienen a las
redes
por tanto los exponemos en las redes en
tercer lugar dejamos que duerman con el
teléfono en vez de decirles hijo mío
apágalo
nosotros mismos en los chats de papas no
me digan los whatsapp de papá son una
suerte de toxina permanente si es que no
las controlamos entonces de alguna
manera de alguna manera estos niños
están creciendo en un mundo totalmente
distinto y nosotros estamos para los
guisados yo tengo una hija adolescente
de 13 años y la verdad es que no puedo
pretender de alguna manera enseñarle a
vivir en este mundo hiperconectado y tal
no lo que puedo decir es que nosotros
desde el derecho hemos tratado de hacer
algo porque como trabajamos con las
palabras trabajamos con los consensos
sociales y trabajamos con en general con
con la contención social o con la forma
como la sociedad se va desenvolviendo
hemos hecho algo en el año 2001 en
budapest en la ciudad de budapest se
reunieron los estados y acordaron el
convenio de budapest para los efectos de
perseguir los ilícitos que se cometan en
las redes dentro de los cuales están el
bullying sexting osea sexo no compartido
imágenes de sexo explícito
compartidas entre la red cierto sin
embargo si sacan la cuenta de él el
derecho llega cuando hay consenso social
pero para que haya consenso social
tienen que haber habido hartos estos
nocivos previamente el derecho llega
tarde nosotros llegamos cuando la
sociedad se ha puesto de acuerdo en un
tema pero para ponerse de acuerdo en ese
tema tienen que haber muerto mucho
piensen ustedes en las cartas de
derechos de 1.280 cuando llegaron
después el señor feudal se había cargado
todo el pueblo las cartas de derechos
después de la revolución francesa
llegaron después de que le habían
cortado la cabeza a todos y así
sucesivamente entonces en este minuto
que nosotros estamos en un momento de
cambio planetario porque no es chile el
que está en revolución sino que el
planeta entero la verdad es que el
derecho también va a llegar tarde y por
tanto mi reflexión es
después de esto no claro efectivamente
tenemos un convenio duda pues tenemos
una red que se llama 24/7 donde trabaja
para que lo sepan una red donde están
las fiscalías de todo el mundo han al
fondo que han logrado prevenir suicidios
juveniles por ejemplo frente a
situaciones de bullying y maltrato en
las redes pero la verdad es que cuando
ha llegado el derecho ya hay gente
muerta ya hay gente enojada y nosotros
ahora que estamos tratando de cambiar la
constitución es también porque hemos
llegado a una situación de enojo que no
son ni siquiera 30 años son 300 años
1800 ahora de una sociedad patriarcal de
una sociedad con un patrón de fondo que
es el que manda la sociedad y la ley la
de alguna manera la abusa entonces la
verdad es que pensemos por tanto qué
hacemos para que de aquí en adelante
nuestros niños que van a crecer en esta
sociedad y por conectada en donde van a
pensar en algo y se les va a aparecer
a ustedes les tiene que haber pasado
cuántas veces han pensado en eso en algo
y después abren el computador y
mágicamente les ofrecen lo que ustedes
pensaron es porque las redes están
conectadas estamos todos conectados y de
alguna manera vamos generando una cierta
una suerte de exposición nosotros
estamos como en una pecera cambio me
imagino el palacio de cristal de madrid
o una pecera en donde uno está el centro
y todos están observando te y de alguna
manera están decidiendo por ti frente a
esa evidencia que hacemos con nuestros
hijos ultra expuestos sobre expuesto
creo yo que tenemos que volver al o al
mismo pensamiento de toda la vida porque
la gente está enojada hoy día porque se
ha visto afectada su dignidad porque
está enojada a la gente hoy día porque
ha visto que los derechos básicos
aquellos por los que lucharon durante
mucho tiempo no se están respetando el
derecho a la salud el derecho a la
educación el derecho a la vivienda digna
a la vida digna el derecho a la muerte
digna ese es un tema que se está
debatiendo a nivel internacional yo
muero cuando sea vivo mientras sea digno
vivir entonces
que al final que un lo que uno piensa
que tendría que enseñarle a sus hijos
hija yo le enseñaba aprecia a mí me
enseñaron no te sientes a la mesa con
las manos sucias tratemos de buscar esas
enseñanzas ancestrales que nos dieron
nuestros padres y traducirlas al
lenguaje computacional e interconectado
de hoy día no te laves no no te sientes
en la mesa sin lavarte las manos
tu computador mantenlo limpio no instale
software de cualquier parte
qué más nos decían no hables con
extraños en la calle
hoy día les tenemos que decir no hables
con cualquiera en la red aquel que
simula ser su amigo puede que no sea tu
amigo no lo conoces no sabes quién es
hay redes mundiales que hacen entrega de
pornografía infantil a partir de engaños
a niños que los hacen en definitiva ir
cumpliendo retos en los cuales
progresivamente se van sobre exponiendo
no hables con cualquiera no hables con
extraños adicionalmente uno les dice
trata bien al otro o no cuantas veces
mejor no trates hacia tu hermano trata
bien al otro habla solo cuando tus
palabras sean amables y no sean una
ofensa al otro
no escribas mensajes ofensivos a tus
compañeros nosotros mismos hablas solo
cuando vayas a decirle algo amoroso el
resto cierto él al final son los mismos
valores de siempre que ahora están
traspasado a nuestra nueva forma de
comunicarnos nuestra nueva forma de
relacionarnos cierto porque el derecho
lo que hace en definitiva es recoger
este consenso social establecer normas y
patrones en las que estamos de acuerdo
que debieran ser transparentes para
nosotros porque les voy a dar un mensaje
que me imagino que ustedes no sé si
todos lo habrán advertido pero en este
país y en general en todo el mundo
cuando uno nace le dan una palmada uno
llora y se sabe todo el derecho
porque porque legalmente
constitucionalmente el derecho se
presume conocido de todos de hecho es
una presunción de mala fe decir que uno
no se sabe la norma
entonces para que uno llegue a poder
exigirle eso a la sociedad el derecho
tiene que ser necesariamente el fruto
del consenso social y por eso llega
tarde no es porque seamos tan malos los
abogados sino porque llega tarde llega
cuando ya hay consenso por eso se
demoran tanto los procesos legislativos
porque hay que lograr el consenso porque
van a ser las reglas que naturalmente la
gente va a entender que son las que
rigen esa sociedad entonces tratemos de
enseñarle a los niños a convivir en esta
nueva red planetaria ahora a comunicarse
con todos estos millones de personas en
base a los valores ancestrales de toda
la vida que son los que han permitido
que llegamos a hacer la sociedad que
somos hoy en día y que seamos capaces de
reconducir el proceso social y
reconducir el proceso normativo hacia
una mejor una mejor convivencia social y
un mejor amparo los derechos estamos hoy
en día en una revolución jurídica ya hay
una las revoluciones no son una cosa de
hoy día han sucedido ya les hablé de un
par cierto en en una primera revolución
logramos unas cosas que se llaman los
derechos de primera generación los
derechos de primera generación
pretendían mantener al hombre vivo
mantenía en mantener al hombre libre
y que fuera juzgado por el juez natural
por sus vecinos por alguien igual a él
en el fondo no por un monarca que
tuviese poder en la segunda revolución
que hicimos que además ese hombre libre
vivo y juzgado por su paz lo
fortaleciera muy un poquitito y le dimos
los derechos sociales y culturales
educados en que tuviese una buena
educación en la tercera revolución y la
tercera evolución los derechos de
tercera generación del timo además
derechos políticos que fueran capaces de
elegir a sus pares hoy en día estamos
asistiendo a una cuarta revolución de
los derechos y por tanto un nuevo
fortalecimiento de esta misma capa de
derechos libertad dignidad y vida con en
el fondo está híper conexión entonces
también hay derechos que sé que sé que
se están debatiendo hoy día como por
ejemplo el acceso universal a las redes
de comunicación es cierto que tengamos
todo un teléfono o una comunicación
servicio y acceso universal y por tanto
educación amplificada a través de las
redes de comunicaciones etcétera sin
embargo eso no aparte de la nada tiene
que partir
desde este hombre fortalecido que sabe
comunicarse y que sabe estar a la altura
eso a nosotros como abogados no impone
un desafío en el sentido de que tenemos
que tener normas iguales alrededor del
mundo pero también como padres no impone
desafíos porque tenemos que enseñarles a
los niños a vivir en este mundo y
nosotros no crecimos ahí nosotros
crecimos en un mundo donde donde
jugábamos a la ronda en el patio
etcétera pero si se fijan se acuerdan y
yo por lo menos el otro día preparando
esto reflexionaba que cuando yo era niña
jugaba una cosa que decían cuántos panea
leyera y en el horno cuarto españa y el
en horno 25 y un quemado ya quien los
quemó
es un maltrato
eso es discriminación
sin embargo nosotros alegremente
jugábamos eso
en una época además en plena en plena
guerra fría entonces de alguna manera
piensen ustedes que todos esos patrones
de maltrato que los niños reproducen las
redes son parte del conocimiento
ancestral que nosotros les transmitimos
alegremente
y por tanto la reflexión mía es vamos a
tener un mundo más amistoso más amable
donde el derecho sea evidente para todos
nosotros porque refleja el consenso y
ahí vamos a restablecer la paz
con el planeta con el otro
y también con nosotros mismos es muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]